the Oscar goes to Octavia Spencer  Octavia Spencer's it seems that we build  spaceman she won an Oscar  maybe we want to know  to be honored for doing  I thought she was born to do this is her  first Academy Award  oh thank you  Thank You Academy for putting me with  the hottest guy in the room um I have to  thank my family's my family in Alabama  the state of Alabama uh um my la family  watching it Stevens or I gotta I help  family Tate Brunson Katherine um Allison  Chani  thank you for being in my life I share  this with everybody Thank You Steven  Spielberg for change in my life thank  you Stacy Snyder for changing my life  please wrap up I'm wrapping up I'm sorry  I'm freaking out thank you world Oh God  and thank you to w me in viewpoint ela  I'm sorry guys I love you thank you I'm  sorry